[Music]
the problem of having a machine
understand human speech has been around
in research for a very long time but now
at Microsoft we are on the verge of
having a tool available to all that
allows us to speak universally with
anyone on the planet for over a decade
we try to develop the means for
improving speech recognition using
Gaussian mixture models all of that
changed when our researchers got
together and decided to take a new look
at the use of deep neural Nets applied
to speech recognition now the new gold
standard in speech research is a long
game by getting smarter every day and
sticking with an understanding the value
of basic research we eventually get to a
point where wonderful things can happen
imagine being able to speak in German
and have your message conveyed
grammatically and semantically correct
in English that future is here with a
Skype translator
it all starts just as with any other
Skype call you just call someone
but now the difference is the person
you're calling doesn't have to speak
your language each day guest on Kashyyyk
table but I wanted to talk to you about
the email that I sent you yesterday
Goffman or organ breaker and doorman do
you need any changes there was one thing
though could you change the green to a
lighter shade Contin see does go into an
inhaler and five tone and then yeah the
color does green Phil Halima yes we can
make the green much brighter it's then
that the orator armed on annoy editor
I'm sending you a new file tonight that
sounds great I look forward to it that's
clean time with a Skype translator it's
a full human to human interaction that
crosses the language barrier it's truly
a magical experience
you